[Music]
welcome back to SEO foundations in this
video we're going to cover on-page
optimization title tags title tags are
the single most important on-page metric
that we have access to this is text that
we get to express that we get to write
that shows the intent and the purpose of
that page on the Internet this is really
really important because search engines
use this this text that we get to
provide in their search results directly
so we get to write what becomes the
headline of the search result itself
this in addition to the Meta Description
as we'll cover next are the two factors
that we have a whole lot of control over
that influence both click-through rates
and people's first impressions of our
brand next up we have meta descriptions
now meta descriptions are a little bit
confusing because it is text that we get
to provide to search engines but more
often than not they override what we
provide and try to choose something that
is better in their opinion now I go both
ways with this sometimes it really is
better
most the time though in my opinion it's
not but the important thing here is that
we get to provide what would normally
we'd have to pay for with ad copy we get
to provide it for free customize it to
however we want to entice to entice
clicks and the search engines are happy
to promote that and show that in the
search results hey once you become an
expert in digital marketing then
subscribe to the simple earn Channel and
click here to watch more such videos
turn up and get certified in digital
marketing click here